without inspectors in north korea the
iaea relies on satellite images using
these it says it's detected a discharge
of cooling water at the main nuclear
plant in yangbian and that suggests the
reactor is operating
if the latest findings are correct the
u.n nuclear watchdog says it's a deeply
troubling development it's believed
yongbyon's reactor produced plutonium
for north korea's nuclear arsenal in the
past
the white house says the iaea report
underscores the urgent need for dialogue
and diplomacy whatever warmer relations
that appeared to be cultivated under
former president donald trump seemed to
have grown cold under his successor joe
biden as u.s military exercises were
held with the south
unfortunately the biden administration
has been slow off the mark on the north
korea file of course they were dealing
with the renewal of the
strategic arms reduction treaty with
russia which happened in february
the resumption of talks with iran on the
comprehensive plan of action fighting
with kobed and also the withdrawal from
afghanistan so these are a number of
important programs but unfortunately
it seems that the united states
traditional position has not changed the
old demand for complete irreversible
verifiable disarmament
of north korea's nuclear program has
never worked and is not likely to work
the subject of consternation and
negotiation for decades young beyond is
the heart of north korea's nuclear
program its cooling tower was famously
destroyed in 2008 as part of an
international drive to dismantle parts
of the program in exchange for relief
from sanctions the following year north
korea kicked monitors out
nearly a decade later kim jong-un
offered to dismantle yong bion in return
for the same concessions the trump
administration rejected the offer that
would have left kim with other reactors
in secret sites not to mention possible
nuclear weapons the weapons are what
give north korea leverage right if
they've got you know 30 instead of 20 or
100 instead of you know 50 or whatever
we don't know how many they have um then
this gives them more bargaining tips
when eventually negotiations take place
by apparently allowing the world to see
this new activity at yongbyon the north
korean leader may be signaling he's
ready to talk
andrew chappelle al jazeera